تعال إلى هنا ،
يمكنك أن تعانقهم ،
هذا جميل جدًا
، هذا عناق جيد ، أحد الأشياء التي
أراد والدي أن يفعلها هو أن يكون قادرًا على العناق
مرة أخرى ما كنت تقول أنك فاتتك فعله
للناس ،
أعانقهم ، نعم كيفن إيوبانكس هو إيميلي  والد سيسكو
أصيب بجلطة دماغية قبل ثماني سنوات مما تسبب في
ضعف ذراعه اليسرى وجعل من الصعب
احتضانه بكلتا ذراعيه.
من خلال العمل مع عميل حقيقي
واجهنا والدها ، لذا
كان قادرًا على إخبار الطلاب كيف
فاته الصيد
وكيف فاته قضاء الوقت مع أحفاده
لاريسا غارسيا ليزا جيمس إيريكا
دكستر وكيسي بارسونز جنبًا إلى جنب مع بقية
طلاب الفصل بطرق العصف الذهني  لمساعدة
eubanks ، كانت إيريكا مثابرة جدًا على
الرغم من أنها كانت مثل الرجال ، أعتقد أن هذا هو
كما تعلمون ، هذا هو
الشخص الذي نحتاج إلى التركيز عليه وقد انضممنا جميعًا
إلى تلك المجموعة
تذكرت أن البنوك الإلكترونية فاتتها العناق ، لذا
بحثوا عن المواد
وبدءوا العمل ، ولد العناق مرة أخرى
وكان eubanks ممتنًا لهذا الإنشاء.
انظر إلى البنوك الإلكترونية وهي تعانق
أسرته كثيرًا
، كما كان الملايين من الآخرين سعداء أيضًا ،
فقد تمكنت eubanks من العناق مرة أخرى ، فقد
يكون هذا شيئًا يمكن أن يساعد ليس
فقط واحدًا ولكن الكثير من العملاء